mais moi c'est une création une mémoire
et montréalais c'est une création dix
ans d'histoire qui répond à un vrai
besoin parce que chercher de
l'information sur l'histoire des
immigrants montréal de bonnes chances
parce que c'est souvent éclaté il ya
donc il faut vraiment chercher très beau
coup pour le trouver et donc on décide
nous d'aller à la recherche de la petite
histoire de montréal pour connaître la
grande alors ça veut dire que nous ce
qu'on fait c'est qu'on se dit tiens si
on faisait l'histoire à partir des
choses qu'on voit dans la rue des petits
commerces des gens qu'on rencontre les
langues qu'on entend dans les rues de
montréal le patrimoine qu'on voit aussi
à droite à gauche
c'est comme ça qu'on fait d'histoire
donc ce qu'on trouve dans mémoires des
montréalais et dans mémoires des
migrations
c'est vraiment la petite histoire au
quotidien de montréal
et cette histoire me permet de raconter
la grande des grands événements les
grands phénomènes les grands moments de
l'histoire de la ville donc on est
autant des choses comme l'histoire
d'expo 67 avec des grandes aussi qu'un
histoire de monsieur tout le monde d'un
chilien par exemple qui est arrivé à
montréal dans les années 70 après la
chute du président allende et son
histoire à lui mais ça devient une
histoire de tous les chiliens qui sont
arrivés à montréal alors c'est ça mais
brady moyen des mémoires des migrations
la petite histoire pour connaître la
crainte